In the 21st century machine learning is rapidly
becoming an integral part of everyday life.
Every month there are huge advances in the field of
artificial intelligence and machine learning
andespecially in the field of image sciences.
Anytimeyou are dealing with images there is so much thatmachine learning has to offer,
and previouslyalmost unimaginable tasks, like like turning astatic image of the Mona Lisa into a movie
are nowpossible with some of these techniques for machinelearning.
So this begs the question how much of
this technology, how much of machine learning,
can actually carry over into the physical sciences
and engineering
and in particular in my field ofengineering fluid mechanics.
I'm Steve Brunton andI'm gonna walk you through how machine learningcan be used for fluid mechanics in a numberof vignettes and examples
So this is a hugefield with absolutely massive progress happening
in machine learning
for the physical sciences,for dynamical systems, and especially for
fluid mechanics,
where we have such vast and increasing amounts of data from simulations andfrom experiments.
I'm gonna walk you through ata very high level some of my favorite examples andapplications
of how machine learning is being usedfor fluid mechanics today.
Good so I want to startby kind of just walking you through what I thinkof when I think of machine learning especiallyapplied to engineering systems.
Fluid mechanicsare absolutely everywhere fluids play a centralrole in nearly every trillion-dollar industry
health defense transportation energy we literally
live and work inside of a fluid and so do all ofour machines.
Most of the tasks that we have
in fluid mechanics, for example model reduction
or getting reduced order models; controlling
those those fluid flows;
figuring out where toput sensors to measure them; and closure models toreduce the complexity
these really critical fluiddynamics tasks will important in solving many ofthe technological challenges of the next century.
So if you think of any science-fiction vision ofthe future a lot of that is going to be enabledby advanced fluid mechanics models and controls
So better energy systems better transportationsystems, you name it, again fluids are going to beplaying a central part in that.
and what I want topoint out is that all of these tasks or almostall of these tasks in fluid mechanics cannaturally be written as hard optimization problems.
So these optimization problems and fluids arevery challenging that's why it's hard to makeprogress in these fields that's why they're soimportant.
These optimizations are nonlinear,
non-convex, multi scale, very high dimensional
but I want to point out that that is exactly
what machine learning is getting really goodat.
So if I want a pigeonhole or kind of make
a blanket statement about machine learning
I'm going to say the machine learning is building models
from data using optimization
or more generally,machine learning is a growing set of techniquesfor optimization
for really high dimensional, non-convex optimizations based on a growing wealthof data
So machine learning is optimization with data and most of the problems we havein fluid mechanics can be naturally writtenas optimization problems.
So these go togetherextremely naturally and what we're gonna seeis that lots and lots of techniques for machinelearning
can be directly applied to solving thesefluids optimization problems like modeling, control,sensing, and so on
and I want to point out when Isay high dimensional I mean that the fluid flowitself has many many many degrees of freedom
I might need a million or billion degrees of freedom
to simulate a turbulent fluid in a computer
so it's very high-dimensional. It's nonlinear because
it's governed by a nonlinear partial differentialequation
the Navier-Stokes equation and those
combined to make these optimization problems
very non-convex, so there's tons of local minima
in these optimization problems
but again we'regonna use emerging techniques in machine learningto start gaining traction in these fluiddynamics tasks
and I want to point out you know
machine learning is not magic a lot of a lot of
people who are not kind of in machine learning
research or have a background in applied math
or statistics you know when I talk to business
leaders oftentimes our initial conversations
they think the machine learning is like you know
a Harry Potter magic wand and you just have a
problem and you point your machine learning at
it and it becomes solved and that's not at all
how this works okay so this is really important
to dispel kind of this myth that machine learning
is magic this is very understandable in terms
of linear algebra optimization and statistics
and I think this is really important we can't
let machine learning become a black box where
it's indistinguishable from magic and so to that
point we need not just machine learning solutions
in physical sciences and in fluid mechanics but
we desperately need models that are interpretable
and generalizable models that we can understand
and communicate and work with and models that we
can trust will work even in new situations that
we haven't seen before and so instead of kind of
rigorously defining what I mean by these I want to
give you an example so I think of Newton's second
law F equals MA as the ultimate interpretable
and generalizable model okay its interpretive
all because it's very simple there's only you know
it's in terms of force mass and acceleration and
it's generalizable in the sense that Newton can
discover this law from an apple falling on a tree
on earth and this law still works when we design
rocket mission from the earth to the moon okay so
this model is interpretable and generalizable
it covers a range of phenomena even phenomenon
oftentimes that we hadn't seen before okay so
this is what we want in our machine learning
models especially when we apply these to systems
in engineering like fluid mechanics where they
might be safety-critical where it might be a part
of a system on an airplane or in a car okay and I
love this quote you've heard me say this before
or quote quote Einstein before everything should
be made as simple as possible but not simpler
and this principle of parsimony or if simplicity
is one of the is that we promote machine
learning models that are both interpretable
and generalizable and so mathematically what we're
looking for oftentimes are models that are sparse
so they only have a few terms like F equals MA or
e equals mc-squared low-dimensional so they're not
in terms of a million degrees of freedom like
a fluid my dynamic simulation would be and we
want them to be robust in lots of ways robust to
noise and disturbances robust to bad information
that goes into the training and robust to new
scenarios that we haven't seen before okay so
this is what we want in a kind of machine learning
for fluid mechanics in general now I want to point
out a lot of what I'm going to talk about in
this video and in in future videos related are
following this review paper that I wrote with
Barrett Nowak and Petros Kunitz aqus on machine
learning for fluid mechanics this is in the annual
review of fluid mechanics from 2020 and you can
download this paper on the archive so here's a
figure that didn't make it into the the review
but I like this this figure a lot and it kind
of at a very high level points out that fluid
dynamics generates tremendous amounts of data
so we have theory simulations and experiments
that are kind of generating this fluid dynamics
data and machine learning can be thought of this
as this common information processing framework so
that you can integrate this flow data and use that
to start solving these really hard optimization
problems in modeling and control and reduction
okay so this is really critical is this kind
of common framework to understand all of this
fluids data and just a point of history I think
this is kind of fun so so Barrington Petrus and I
started working on this review together actually
we had separate conversations about the history
of machine learning in fluids so it turns out
that fluid mechanics is one of the kind of old
and original fields where machine learning grew
out of so fluids has tons of big data a lot of
computational architectures and algorithms were
developed specifically to handle fluids problems
and in this example it this is kind of a neat
example that shows that a lot of these concepts in
optimization and stochastic optimization actually
go back pretty are in fluids so in the 60s and 70s
in in Berlin Reichenberg and sh Zweifel kind of
pioneered the use of evolutionary algorithms or
genetic algorithms to design and optimize better
flow systems so in this experiment they have this
multi panel plate where you can change the angle
of these plates and they were trying to find an
optimal configuration that would reduce the
drag on this configuration and so running an
optimization that included some aspects of
stochasticity so this is AG Alton board or
Galton brecht which is basically a Plinko game
if you like the prices right you drop a little
ball in here and it bounces around and if you
sample from this distribution of where that ball
falls it's effectively sampling from a binomial
or a Gaussian distribution and they use that to
introduce stochasticity into their optimization
so they did some kind of a stochastic gradient
type descent to find an optimal configuration
and in in the end it actually turned out not
to be exactly flat which is really interesting
now you should read more about this history it's
it's pretty neat and there was kind of a debate
at the time about how this fit into the larger
field of fluid mechanics research was this fluid
mechanics research and increasingly we're finding
today that kind of these optimizations and flow
physics you know they're very tightly linked and
so the field of fluid mechanics is intrinsically
linked to data driven optimizations there's also
this really nice connection this to this kind of
AI winter in this video by by Sir James light Hill
and so I think I'm just gonna play this this is
Sir light Hill essentially holding some of the
leading AI researchers at the time in the 70s
on trial so he his argument was that machine
learning and artificial intelligence had gone
through this massive hype cycle they had been
hyping and hyping and hyping the promise of AI how
it's going to change everything speech recognition
natural language processing and that research had
fundamentally failed to deliver on these promises
and so this trial and his subsequent report
the light Hill report actually was a pivotal
played a pivotal role in the so-called AI winter
that really resulted in a massive cut in funding
for decades in artificial intelligence research
it's kind of ironic and Petros pointed this out
I think this is really funny that one of
light Hill's criticisms of AI was that it
didn't deliver on natural language processing
and here we're watching this YouTube video
that is being automatically transcribed by a
computer algorithm so something has changed
in the last twenty thirty years a lot of it is
based on better algorithms better computational
hardware and open source frameworks where you can
actually start to integrate these algorithms and
data easily and efficiently and in a community
kind of reproducible setting okay so so a lot
has changed since then and were able to do a lot
more than we weren't before so I'm gonna walk you
through some vignettes just kind of highlighting
areas of applications that I see machine learning
being super important in fluids research and
then later we'll do kind of deeper dives into
into these topics and again this is very shallow
this is the tip of the iceberg there is tons of
good out work out there that I'm I'm not covering
right now but in my perspective on kind of fluid
mechanics in general and this is with or without
machine learning one of the things that makes
fluids interesting and beautiful to humans and
and somewhat tractable that gives us some hope
that we can model and control these things is that
patterns exist even in very very complicated flows
like this flow this cloud flow over r-e shiri
island at japan there are these big dominant
patterns or coherent structures that resemble much
much simpler flows that we can actually model and
simulate and control quickly and and robustly this
is a picture from a review paper by Sam Tyra and
co-authors in the AIW journal from 2017 I think
this is a really nice review paper that talks
about kind of how patterns exist in fluids and how
you can extract them and this this basic theme of
patterns existing is one of the major entry points
of machine learning into fluid mechanics and in
fact I would say that a lot of machine learning
research really is aimed around either extracting
or characterizing or utilizing low-dimensional or
dominant patterns in big data like image data or
flow field data and so a lot of that carries over
very directly if you think of your flow field as a
picture and if you think of the time evolution of
your flow field as a movie of moving pictures then
a lot of machine learning carries over directly
okay so one of our kind of go-to algorithms for
for pulling out patterns in fluid flows is the
proper orthogonal decomposition this is basically
a principal components analysis done on flow
data where you take a movie of your flow field
this is just flow past a cylinder at low Reynolds
number 100 and if you subtract off the average
flow field and do a singular value decomposition
or a principal component analysis you find that
you can very efficiently represent this fluid flow
as the sum of only a few kind of eigen flow fields
or these these proper these large amplitude
principal components okay so patterns exist
you can pull out those patterns and you can get
a much much simpler representation of your flow
so instead of needing a million degrees of freedom
if this was a megapixel image I might only need 10
p OD modes and how they vary in time okay and so
this idea that there are low dimensional patterns
in fluids allows you to do really really powerful
things essentially take algorithms directly from
image processing and apply them to flow data so
this is work by Isabelle Sherrill who's a PhD
student working with Brian Paolo G and myself and
in this example what she did was she took that low
Reynolds number coherent flow past a cylinder and
added a ton of salt and pepper corruption so each
pixel has a random chance of being completely
corrupted not additive noise but like just you
know blacked out essentially and using these
algorithms from robust statistics these kind
of modern optimization techniques that leverage
patterns and the data she's able to decompose
this flow into the true low rank component that's
characterized by only a few PID modes and all of
that salt and pepper noise so she's able to split
the data into kind of the clean data that we want
and all of this salt-and-pepper noise and this
is really very interesting you should check out
her paper there's a lot more examples and details
but we think this is particularly interesting and
important for experimental flow measurements
so a lot of fluids are still characterized in
laboratories because our computers just aren't
powerful enough to simulate all of the degrees
of freedom of flow past a submarine or a jumbo
jet and so we do a lot of laboratory experimental
testing but those experimental measurements might
be quite noisy and they might have lots of kind
of TV static and a-looking noise on top and so
Isabelle's algorithm or her adaptation of this
robust principal components algorithm allows you
to clean up that experimental data and get much
higher fidelity flow estimates so that's one area
where where machine learning can be used is by
just leveraging those patterns and the data as if
they were sequences of images another kind of area
where patterns exist is in kind of getting closure
models for very very very complex flows so this
is one of my favorite simulations by my colleagues
at kth in Sweden where they're essentially running
this massive massive boundary layer simulation
so this is an extremely computationally expensive
simulation of a turbulent boundary layer and
what you see here is that there are these massive
massive separation of scales so there's little
small scales these kind of horseshoe vortices
they're rising up out of the fluid but then
every time you zoom out you see more and more
and more kind of structure and detail across this
incredible span of length scales and time scales
and this is common in all real world turbulent
fluids so flow over a wing or over a boat or a car
or in an engine over a windmill blade you're gonna
get this kind of turbulent separated structures
over this range of scales but again there are
patterns again it exists there are large scale
structures that matter for drag and for lift and
for mixing for efficiency and so we might not want
to characterize every single degree of freedom in
this extremely expensive simulation but instead
we might want to get a reduced order model for
how the big energy containing structures work
together to change the drag on this this boundary
layer for example okay and so this is a classic
picture for anyone who studied turbulence this
is the Kolmogorov turbulent energy cascade which
basically shows that if you have a turbulent flow
you're going to have this massive scale separation
so the x-axis is basically spatial scales on
a log plot so big vertical structures are here
on the left little teeny tiny vortical structures
are here on the right and real-world fluids might
have many many many orders of magnitude of scales
both in space and time and so instead of resolving
all of this which is very expensive for computers
this is why we have the biggest supercomputers in
the world are often built to solve these problems
but instead of modeling all of these scales is it
possible to approximate how these small scales
affect the big energy containing scales that we
actually care about because these are often what
we care about for a lift and drag and and things
like that and so this is a massive Field called
closure modeling and it's really really important
it's been a focus and fluids research for decades
and there's this great review paper by DeRosa me
yeah Kirino and Shou called turbulence modeling
in the age of data where they really dive into
how machine learning and data-driven methods
are being used to tackle this closure problem
and I think this is one of the most exciting areas
where where kind of machine learning research can
really make a practical impact on actual everyday
industrial flows and this is just one example from
one paper this is one of my favorite papers on the
topic topic of Rands modeling this is the Reynolds
average navier-stokes modeling where you need to
close this model to account for small-scale and
fast terms that you don't want to resolve fully
and so what Ling and colleagues did was instead
of just using the big deep neural network which
would be the most obvious kind of first thing you
might try what they did was design a custom deep
neural network with these additional tensor input
layers that essentially allowed them to encode or
enforce prior physical knowledge about fluid flows
so fluid flows are not just unstructured images
or movies we know that there's physics there's
conservation of energy and mass and momentum
there are symmetries and what they were able
to do in this paper was embed some of those
symmetries and invariants invariants directly
in their neural network so that their simulation
or their closure is physical by construction and
I think this is a beautiful example of what
we all should be thinking about when we apply
machine learning to physical systems is how do
we bake in prior knowledge to make it so that
our models are not just accurate but they're
also physical okay so really great paper you
got to check this out it's a classic in the field
now okay so other areas that are really important
super-resolution is a technology that is really
big in image sciences and of course we can apply
this directly to flow fields if we think about
them as images so this is data from the Johns
Hopkins turn turbulence data set and if you
train on a large collection of images like
these in a movie flow field images then you can
take very low resolution or downsample versions
of the flow field and reconstruct kind of this
super resolution high resolution image with all
of the flow details so this is closely related
to that closure problem is the super resolution
problem again of taking either low resolution data
from experiments or maybe this is a fast cheap and
dirty simulation and being able to kind of fill in
the details by leveraging a large offline training
database to give you the statistics of what flow
fields actually look like very cool emerging field
lots of work being done here and I'll just point
out this is so important I have to I have to tell
you about this this image I'm showed up here I've
shown up here that gives you this beautiful almost
perfect reconstruction of the flow field from
this low resolution and down sampled image that's
what happens if you run this super resolution
algorithm as an interpolator okay so what that
means is these kind of dark gray columns are where
you train the data and we randomly pepper them
throughout this movie so time is evolving in this
movie and we randomly pull frames of that movie to
Train this algorithm and then we test it on this
test frame which is at one of these blue locations
that's kind of between data we've already sampled
and so this is fundamentally an interpolation
task because this blue column is kind of closely
related to the two images right before and right
after it in the movie that we're in the training
data but if we do an extrapolation task and this
is much more realistic for many flow problems
like if you wanted to use this to predict the
weather in the future how the you know the flow
field around planet Earth will look next month
or next year that's a future extrapolation problem
so in that case you'd be using all of this as your
training data all the past and you'd be trying
to predict the future and this extrapolation is
much much harder so you can see here these are
the truth flow fields on top and as you start
to extrapolate forward and for farther in time
the first snapshots actually pretty good but
as you go further and further in time you get
terrible degradation in the reconstruction so
huge caveat extrapolation is always hard and you
have to add more physics to make that to make that
work okay that's a much harder problem you have
to be careful about if you're interpolating or
extrapolating good so we already talked about how
peyote and proper orthogonal decomposition can be
used to great advantage to decompose a flow field
into its dominant patterns and decades ago it was
actually shown that this kind of p OD or principal
components analysis could be written as a shallow
kind of one hidden layer auto-encoder neural
network so you can do this principal components
analysis in a neural network frame framework and
what's really nice is that you can then generalize
or expand that neural network to have many many
many hidden layers and nonlinear activation
functions so you can build these deep autoencoders
that give you much much better signal compression
and reduction so you would have the input be your
high resolution flow image or flow field and in
the middle layer these are kind of the latent
variables or the dominant coherent structures and
then the decoder would use those few variables
to reconstruct an estimate of the full flow
field image so this is kind of an information
bottleneck that compresses and then decompresses
your your flow field and I'll point out that
milano and Kumud sockets in 2002 I believe
were the earliest to apply this concept to fluid
mechanics in a really really great paper I think
that was way ahead of its time people are now
you know two decades later in full force trying
to apply these auto-encoders to fluid they had it
in 2002 so go check out that paper okay good you
can also use these concepts to build reduced
order models so once you have those patterns
extracted through either P OD or an autoencoder
let's say for the flow field then you can get
very very simple representations for example
in those low dimensional coordinate systems in
those autoencoder coordinates the dynamics might
behave very simply like they might live on this
parabolic Bowl this is what Barret Nowak showed
in 2003 and then you can use these coordinates
and use data-driven methods like Cindy the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics to build very
very efficient models for how these modes evolve
in time purely for measurement data and there's a
lot of great work on this jean-christophe Lazo
from Paris has been innovating a ton of cool
methods for applying this Sindhi method to fluids
problems to enforce known physics and to get
really accurate and efficient models of complex
flow systems okay good so maybe kind of one of
the the last applications of this once you have
your models and you've extracted your patterns
one of the ultimate goals is to actually control
your fluid you don't just want to understand it
and model it you want to manipulate your flow and
so flow control is not this this is what people
think about a lot of times is kind of again magic
you could to magically manipulate what your flow
does and that's not at all it happens this is a
very principled optimization of your flow field
and of your control law with some objective
in mind okay and again those objectives come
from the real world I want to increase my lift I
want to decrease my drag I might want to increase
mixing in a combustor okay and so those are all
optimization problems so there's nothing magic
about this and these optimization problems can be
solved increasingly well with tools for machine
learning so I really like this diagram from a
paper by katarina beaker and Sebastian pipes which
basically shows that if you have a really really
complicated flow system and you want to control it
instead of using the full Navy or stokes equations
which are far too expensive what you can do is you
can use machine learning to build these surrogate
models that are fast and accurate and fast enough
to use in real time for feedback control so this
is a really nice diagram that you can use for lots
of different types of machine learning models and
lots of different types of control algorithms in
this case they're using model predictive control
and I guess maybe one of the last things I want
to point out is that much of what I'm talking
about in machine learning and in fluid modeling
and control is truly inspired by from biology
so a lot of machine learning came out of wanting
to understand how biological systems how it
brains and nervous systems work so seamlessly
to make decisions and understand and interact
with the world and in fluid mechanics we have
some hope that we can actually interact with and
understand and model and control complex fluids
because biology in some sense provides proof by
existence that it's possible to interact with
these very very complex turbulent flow fields
so this Eagle is performing incredible accurate
or let's say agile and adept maneuvers with out
measurements of the full three-dimensional flow
field presumably without knowledge of the navier's
stokes equations or any advanced degrees in fluid
mechanics the eagle is taking measurements on its
wings and it's experience it's it has learned to
interact with this flow field in an extremely
elegant way that really goes far beyond what
we can do in engineering systems and even beyond
the Eagle I take great inspiration from insects
that fly and lots of us at the University of
Washington are actively working on trying to
understand how insects measure and interact with
complex flow fields because they have very very
simple nervous systems compared to an eagle all
flying insects have strain sensitive neurons on
their wings and they use this information to make
estimation and control decisions about what to do
in their flow environment extremely fascinating
learning systems okay and so we want to know how
we can learn from them in our in our engineering
machine learning for flow control okay good so
that was kind of a very high-level overview of how
machine learning can be used for fluid mechanics
I'll go into more detail and kind of go into
depth and some of those vignettes later but I
really do want to point out that so much work is
being done in this field this is just again the
tip of the iceberg in in the future you should
check and see what has changed even you know
six months from now I guarantee you there will be
new technology that that I didn't know about when
I was making this video so do go check out the
references and and stay tuned because this is an
incredibly interesting but also very important
field of machine learning research thank you